I am Nick Gillespie with Matt Welch this
is ask a libertarian 2012 we're
celebrating the forthcoming release of
the paperback edition of the Declaration
of Independence features a new forward
it updates the book over the past year
please check it out online or at your
nearest bookseller here's our latest
question coming from cereth kerschen a
Swami Jaime sarsen Evan d'oeuvre mr.
James Liberty stateless Liberty and a
bunch of other people and the question
is what about Rhodes I I know the spirit
in which this question is being asked
which is of course always demanding
among libertarians you don't like
government so much how how come you're
using government roads but I think I'm
gonna answer it kind of literally on
some level and not in the sense that it
was asked which is to say libertarian
ideas have a hell of a lot to say about
what about roads right now in America
the preferred mode of transportation for
the moment and for the foreseeable
future is a car those cars go over lousy
roads in cities where they're spending a
lot of taxpayer money on things like
brand new stadiums instead of fixing
potholes and on a highway system and is
woefully underfunded whose money is
being diverted to a bunch of stupid
light rail projects and other things in
vain attempts to get people out of their
cars with libertarian ideas have to do
with all of this Bob Poole great patron
saints of Reason who still sits on the
reason for foundation's board of
trustees one of the foremost
transportation experts in the country he
has been advocating and we're finally
starting to see movement on the idea of
bringing in private capital to build new
road capacity imagine that crazy talk
it's actually happening within miles of
where we stand here in Washington to
relieve terrible congestion we think so
much in terms of governments having
monopoly over these important goods that
no one else can do that we block our own
mental pathways towards figuring out ok
doesn't someone want to make money off
of this and if so can they actually help
these problems that are otherwise seen
as intractable libertarian ideas
specifically have a lot to say about
building improving expanding and
maintaining row
we need to eliminate road blocks away
from implementing those things and I
think now that state and local budgets
federal budgets are so desperate for
cash they are looking towards those
innovative ideas and looking towards
outfits especially like the recent
foundation 501c3 who does that type of
work it's ask a libertarian 2012 we're
going to be right back